bonjour monsieur jouant si merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors tout
d'abord faut-il s'inquiéter pour ses
marins une quarantaine qui présente donc
des symptômes ils sont à bord est ce qu
on peut aussi s'inquiéter pour
l'équipage est ce que finalement le
porte-avions et est armé pour éviter la
propagation du virus
oui le porte-avions et forces armées
dans tous les sens du terme
je crois que les règles militaires de
protection du personnel sont appliqué
avec rigueur
il n'est ce pas un espace de confinement
qui a été définie pour mettre je dirais
à l'abri à la fois l'équipage et les
personnes soupçonnées d'être porteurs du
virus
maintenant ce n'est pas une situation de
gravité exceptionnelle nous sommes face
à une maladie
nous sommes pas avec des personnels qui
sont jeunes suivis du point de vue
sanitaire
bon maintenant je pense que toutes les
mesures sont prises à bord de ce navire
pour tout se passe bien alors on fait
que kylie a à bord une équipe du service
de santé des armées
elle a également beaucoup de moyens sur
place mais aussi des moyens pour
réaliser des tests est ce que votre avis
l'équipage du porte-avions pourra
reprendre sa mission dans ces conditions
particulières dans tous les cas la
ministre des armées a décidé que la
mission s'arrêtait au moins
temporairement
et ce porte-avions avec son groupe
aéronaval se rend sur toulon
effectivement pour peut-être est en
quarantaine on nous sommes dans des
mesures de précaution s'est il
s'agissait essentiellement d'un exercice
en mer dont qui n'a pas de conséquences
opérationnelles grave pour l'instant
et donc oui tout des mesures sont prises
de toute façon que cet équipage à terme
puisse repartir mais aujourd'hui c'est
la santé qui prime pour tous les marins
alors vous l'avez dire il y avait un
exercice en mer on sait que l'équipage
n'a pas remis les pieds à terre depuis
le 15 mars
une pause de trois jours à brest une
question se pose forcément s'il s'avère
que les personnes malades sont infectés
par le comique 19 commente elle est
infecté ce que les marins peuvent avoir
eu des contacts en mer justement c'est
une bonne question à laquelle d'ailleurs
la marine ne peux pas répondre
aujourd'hui son porte parole la vienne
exprimer on ne sait pas comment ce virus
est arrivé à bord dans la mesure où
théoriquement il n'y a eu aucun contact
depuis le 15 16 mars dernier
donc il ya dû y avoir une faille
forcément quelque part j'irai entre
guillemets une enquête essaiera de
déterminer d'où provient cette faille
s'il ya eu un contact humain non prévu
mais pour l'instant nul n'est capable de
dire d'où provient ce début d'épidémie
potentiel puisqu'il n'est pas encore
avérée en tant que telle était sa donc
vont être effectués sur ces 40 personnes
qui sont d'ailleurs placés en
confinement à l'avant du porte-avions
lève pas oui tout à fait et c'est il ya
une capacité d'environ 120 130 personnes
si ça devait s'aggraver
d'autre part c'est une zone qui est mise
sous pression risée donc qui permet en
même temps de préserver le contact avec
l'extérieur
donc ces personnes sont en sécurité
l'équipage est en sécurité
et ça n'entre absolument pas le
fonctionnement du porte avions
clemenceau pardon du porte avions
charles de gaulle aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup en tout cas monsieur
françois chauve ans et d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le général de brigade